-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show" here...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Studio 6A in New York City.
Thank you, Roots.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys,
as of this afternoon,
some states are still
counting their votes,
but the numbers are looking good
for Joe Biden.
Yep, it seems like America --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Seems like America is just about
ready
to socially distance
from President Trump.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep, as more votes
came in today,
the coronavirus
put on its hat and coat
and thought,
"Well, it's been a good run.
Good day to you all."
[ Laughter ]
That's right, as of now,
it's looking like
the GOP strategy of "Hope no one
notices the global pandemic"
didn't turn out so well.
[ Laughter ]
At this very moment, Biden is
smiling from ear to ear.
At least I think he is.
It's hard to tell
since he's wearing a mask!
You should wear a --
You could tell
Biden's feeling good, though.
He spent most of the day
putting the finishing screw-ups
on his acceptance speech.
[ Laughter ]
Later, Biden was seen
swigging Ocean Spray
while hanging off the back
of an Amtrak train.
♪ Thunder only happens
when it's raining ♪
♪♪
Was he drinking while singing?
I don't know what he --
Well, he's going so fast
that there's no liquid --
-Right, exactly.
-It's a lot of space work,
but trust me, it makes sense.
Here's how confident
Biden is feeling.
He just called Trump to say,
"Hey, that crap
about Hunter's laptop?
All true. Bye!"
[ Laughter ]
What you gonna do?
Yeah, the only people happier
than Biden's staff is Trump's.
"Oh, my God. It's almost over.
Thank goodness.
Gosh, that was
a long four years."
I'm not saying
Trump is in trouble,
but he was just sent straight to
voicemail by the MyPillow guy.
[ Laughter ]
But this is nice --
Trump's inner circle
is trying to cheer him up.
They're like, "Yes, you may be
losing the White House,
but on the bright side,
you can now focus
on that cool billion you owe."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Eric Trump was like,
"If Biden is president,
does that mean he's my new dad?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, nothing is definite,
but the outcome feels
pretty inevitable right now.
Vladimir Putin is like,
"Oh, well.
You rig some, you lose some."
[ Laughter ]
You rig some, you lose some.
Trending on Twitter right now.
That's right, things are looking
pretty good for Biden,
but we're still waiting
for a final call,
'cause a few swing states
are still counting final votes.
Seriously,
this is getting crazy.
It's like we're living through
that dramatic pause
before they give out a rose
on "The Bachelorette,"
but for two full days.
You're like, "Okay --
[ Breathing heavily ]
Okay-y-y-y.
[ Drum roll ]
[ Drum roll stops ]
Ah...
[ Drum roll ]
Will you accept -- Eh..."
At this point,
Americans are like, "Let's go.
We've got no things to do,
and no people to see."
[ Laughter ]
I heard Zog's laugh at it.
That's --
[ Laughter ]
But this is interesting.
I heard that each ballot
is processed by two volunteers,
one Democrat and one Republican.
And if they fall in love,
they star in a Hallmark movie
called "Count on Love."
[ Laughter ]
Imagine being
a ballot counter, though.
You're stuck inside
a room full of people
during a global pandemic,
paper cuts all over your hands,
and the rest of the country
is like,
"What the hell
is taking so long?!
I don't hear any counting
in there, Gretchen."
[ Laughter ]
-Gretchen.
It would be a Gretchen.
-It feels like it, right?
You can tell Trump's starting
to panic about the results,
'cause this morning,
he tweeted, "STOP THE COUNT!"
In response, The Count
from "Sesame Street" tweeted,
"You've lost ONE, TWO, THREE
swing states!
AH AH AH"
♪♪
Then a little later in the day,
Trump also tweeted,
"STOP THE FRAUD!"
Yeah, "STOP THE COUNT!"
then "STOP THE FRAUD!"
Soon he's going to tell us to
stop, collaborate, and listen.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
What -- I was trying
to do his dance move,
but does he have a --
Oh, yeah, it was.
It was a lot of --
-A lot of --
-A lot of, like, chain flying?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-It's not skipping rope.
-I'm skipping rope,
but still, it's --
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, do it again.
Do it again. Do it again.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-I'm double dutching.
I'm double dutching.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Sorry, Vanilla.
Sorry.
But he's not just tweeting.
Trump's campaign started
taking legal action yesterday.
Check it out.
-Legal challenges
are already under way.
The Trump campaign has filed
lawsuits in Pennsylvania,
Michigan, and Georgia,
and the campaign is pursuing
a recount of the vote
in Wisconsin.
-You know you're in trouble
when your master plan
starts with, "Get me
Rudy Giuliani on the phone."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, as we speak,
Trump is assembling
a dream team of lawyers
who all claim they were
tucking in their shirts.
[ Laughter ]
Of course --
Of course he's suing.
I get the feeling
when Trump didn't get
the Christmas gift he wanted
as a kid, he was like,
"Better lawyer up, Nana.
[ Laughter ]
Better lawyer up, Nana."
Trending on Twitter.
That's a good one.
"Better lawyer up, Nana."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I read
that Trump is upset
that Fox News called Arizona
for Biden on election night.
And yesterday, Trump's
supporters came to his defense.
Listen to this.
-[ Chanting ] Fox News sucks!
-And they're actually chanting
"Fox News sucks.
Fox News sucks."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's supporters were like,
"We only trust one real news
outlet -- Facebook memes."
[ Laughter ]
You can tell
everyone is on edge.
Sean Hannity just had
an unscaleable wall built
around his studio.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's "DeShay"?
DeShay revolves it?
-Yep.
-It's DeShay, right?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That was a really loud "Yep"
from Mark.
-How'd he --
Yeah, how'd he know that?
-The rest of The Roots
just looked at me.
Mark goes, "Yep.
That's right, it's DeShay."
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
"Check out the hook
while DeShay revolves it."
-Oh, my God.
-Yo, I never --
I thought he said "deejay."
-Nah.
-I thought it was, "Check out
the hook while my deejay re--"
But, yeah.
-No, you'd think that.
-Yeah, one would think.
-One would.
-Yeah.
-And one wouldn't, you know?
-Yep, yep.
You rig some, you lose some.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-That's right.
"Better lawyer up, Nana."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and here's something
you don't hear every day.
A man was banned from
Yellowstone National Park
for trying to fry chickens
in the hot spring.
[ Laughter ]
You see, these are
the stories we can focus on
during a Biden presidency.
Not Trump.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fried chickens in the hot --
I'm too lazy
to microwave a Lean Cuisine.
This guy goes to Wyoming
to cook a 12-piece.
[ Laughter ]
Here's a big business story --
The owner of Arby's
and Buffalo Wild Wings
is buying Dunkin' Donuts
and Baskin-Robbins.
Wow, they now have a monopoly
on clogged arteries.
Here's the plan -- Dunkin' for
breakfast, Arby's for lunch,
Buffalo Wild Wings for dinner,
Baskin-Robbins for dessert,
then you drop your kids back off
at their mother's house.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm dating again, Susan."
And finally, a car in Wisconsin
was just pulled over
for a pretty interesting reason.
Watch this.
-The state trooper
had pulled over a driver
who thought it was a good idea
to strap a snowmobile
to the top of his car.
The 23-year-old driver explained
that it, "looked sketchy,"
but said that
he strapped it down
and he shook it
to make sure it was secure.
[ Laughter ]
-In his defense, that's how
every New Yorker installs
an air conditioner. Yeah.